[Music]
all right what are some tic toc
challenges that you guys know of no I
mentioned multiple during all these
videos every yeah but mentioned it can
for this I literally know none of them
know well there was that pornhub one
where the girlfriend will play up the
pornhub intro and just to see the
boyfriends reaction I'm such a boom oh
yeah yeah that's true
Esther's dancing it's a lot just dancing
it'll be like this challenge because
it's this song this name of the song
they all blend in together right well
this one stands out this one is called
the mugshot challenge oh like real mug
shots no I will play like a mug like a
coffee mug no a mug shot challenge Oh
Meowth
talented these days with the makeup
looks good right it looks really really
realistic that's why I see you like that
and I'm like I'm not going tick-tock I'm
gonna way too far behind the skill
that's gonna take for me to even catch
up is no but then you can like you can
meme yourself with that meme so you show
how bad you are at it and do bad version
yeah but I heard they got a lot of
controversy yes so maybe don't do the
Chad the mug shot and maybe it's not so
cool in the sense of you're making fun
of it then that could work the mug shot
challenge can you show dick on tik-tok
no okay they're very like they're like
you can't show a punch so there's a lot
of things you can do there varies hunch
they're very strict and it's cuz you
know a lot of kids on there so you can't
you could no torquing I depends yeah but
it just depends on like how much you're
showing why would anyone want to do
tick-tock and you're so limiting but
like because there's so many kids I mean
once you have the like you can't do this
you used like because a lot of people
just get popular shaking their ass or
doing a certain type of content or
whatever it may be so they're shaking
their asses for like eight-year-olds
let's put some of them are young people
doing it and in people that's why it's
also another meme for tick-tock where
it's like oh is this person underaged or
not sometimes you can't [ __ ] it
especially on tik-tok but these kids are
dancing you know like holy
and you look at their their age and it's
like 13 I'm less ticked Instagram at
least I know my demographic they're at
least on Instagram you know the women
there are women all right so actually
you don't know all right so this mugshot
challenge has gotten a lot of flack and
controversy B you would typically do
yeah what okay highlight something you
would highlight it yeah well in theory I
think it's a creative concept and I
thought it was cool it's like how would
you if you were to get in trouble with
the law how do you think it would happen
and I think I also like a person who had
a mug shot at the police station I
approve what was your mug shot like I
don't even know what it looked like Bob
head it was just me bald head probably
eyes red from crying and [ __ ] maybe a
little bit of blood coming from my ear
because there was a no what do you call
it
earrings being ripped out and then I had
oh she earrings are ripped out yeah oh I
didn't know you even had earrings I had
cartilage earrings yeah oh so you're
into your cartilage yeah that's the kind
of extra paint wasn't even yet right
that's crazy
well it's not a great idea dude to do
the the mugshot challenge because a lot
of domestic abuse survivors and just
people in general are saying that your
your glamourizing abuse it depends on
how you got to the mug shot yeah I never
pictured this as like you got beat up by
her husband yeah I pictured it as like
you got into a big brawl because then
the person getting the mug shot
generally isn't the one that get abused
it would be like the person that's doing
the abusing right true yeah it's like
you got into a fight in a parking lot
maybe they're just saying abuse in
general only fighting and silver shows
anyone just like that looks like they're
hurt you're like look at this so they're
filling in the blanks here they're
saying like yeah they're jumping to
conclusions I thought
that guy just fell down the stairs while
robbing a store so they got a mug shot
oh yeah well the controversy now has
forced a lot of influencers such as
what's his name James Charles James
Charles to to take down their post oh
that's misleading all the challenge the
mugshot challenges because it's no good
but it's people filling in their own
blinks and there is sooner than I would
agree with that you know what movie I
really liked and they had a whole bunch
of mugshot challenges in it was a Fight
Club mm-hmm like every actor had at
least one of those like a bloody nose
the bull you know like a [ __ ] black I
think the cool thing about this is that
they get to show off their own makeup
skills to the point where they could
probably get jobs you know doing that
true if that's just makeup that's way
better than all these like film people
that make their own movies yeah yeah
that's really good actually some just
movies in general
I didn't even once even cross my mind
that it was a dome at like making
domestic violence cool because the
mystic violence is not [ __ ] cool I
thought the idea was all your showing
how cool criminals are yeah I did see
this tweet that he tweeted up and it
like I'm not a big fan nothing I don't
know James Rosen why is it cuz he's gay
no you sure about that
but it's like I know you're homophobic
have you ever seen his house probably
dopest [ __ ] you it's [ __ ] a castle
he's like 19 it's a it's a [ __ ]
castle Jewish showing me his up place
getting we redecorated every star am i
right yeah wow so he put it off he was a
apologising for but he was like why
can't I do but if all these people were
like these music videos I started
calling out the weekend like Ariana
Grande for doing the same exact thing
but they don't get flack for it but he
was like I'm not calling them out I'm
huge fans of them but there's like a
double standard when it comes to this
yeah it's weird
I think social immediate influencers
have a weird like we were given a
responsibility that we never really
asked for right and you don't have the
luxuries or like the privileges that
like the traditional Hollywood people
have like one of the things I was
talking to about this where like you
know like sometimes you work on with a
big
Brande right and when we work with the
big brand they go okay we need to go
back in your channel they need to
private this this this and this is this
they look at the catalog of work and
then one of my favorite movies is Coco
and Miguel sings like the main Coco song
and Disney was cool at that except his
other catalogue of work is him about
[ __ ] [ __ ] and ha like [ __ ] boughs
to him and then [ __ ] like suck his
dick and all that [ __ ] and I'm like why
the [ __ ] how come like Hollywood they
have like there's a more of a separation
between the person and the art and
there's like this leniency towards a--
versus i guess more social media or
influencer it's like the art and the
person have to have the system actually
with rappers because they talk about
abusing women disrespect humanely all
those things dude I know I've never seen
a feminist like take try to go after any
rapper well maybe it has happened night
I'm sure but not mainstream now in a
mainstream level like if if feminists
really wanted to tackle like the the
modern day is like yeah they should go
after rappers constantly and really try
to get wrapped out of the mainstream
like ear you know may beverages I've
seen porn on women just only through a
rap is [ __ ] all kinds of beverages
just all of them constantly well I think
it's more [ __ ] up and like we probably
wouldn't know about it or it wouldn't
have been that big if it wasn't like a
media company that was just like oh this
is something cool to talk about and now
raises it to so many more people that
jump on and be like this is what you
should think if you don't think this way
you're wrong
so like whoever news article pick this
up is they're trying to like also push
that because they have an agenda to
price you know who's this chick she's
also a tick-tock I don't know her did
you guys know her wait where's her
mugshot right here that's right she
looks like a hotter version of Scarlett
Johansson she looks like she just had a
coke fueled party and she got to jail
her nose is bleeding for all the cokes
she did is on cocaine possession yeah
she did a good job she's yeah I mean
that's what she looks like she's her
eyes be more red you think she looks
like she stood up all night from
partying so it's all kind of [ __ ] up
but I mean it dad my mind it doesn't
even go to like she got beat up
by her boyfriend yeah I didn't think
about that but like what what was for me
was like oh you're kind of like
sensationalizing with someone who is
considered like a bad guy in in in the
situation that's I have two movies that
are made right but like but I guess like
if we're talking about an influencer
needs to be like who they like their art
or whatever I just to me it's just kind
of like okay well I think as an
influencer you're supposed to have like
a more positive like reflection or like
more you got it you gotta set a good
example right and the fact that you're
glorifying something that's like a bad
position I think is I think it depends
on if you're creating something or
you're showing that you're doing that
thing right yeah but but like so looking
at these mug shots like they still look
good that's the thing like if you make
yourself look hella [ __ ] up then I
think that's like hella creative because
like oh cool like how far can you see
they're still looking pretty they're
still yeah this is like Hunger Games how
are you gonna be like surviving for your
life and you still look at prettiest
[ __ ] yeah I mean like I don't know like
what comes across to my mind is like Ted
Bundy you know like he's tall he's a
pretty [ __ ] he killed all these
ladies yeah people glorify his ass but
do you hate like birds of prey kind of
thing then I watch that well I mean like
it's the idea of like all those women
are being bashed but also you know
getting beat up and stuff it's not like
they're good looking super shitty right
right but but what I'm saying is that
they all look like real hot with the mug
shots yeah I don't know I don't know
like I I don't I don't want to like make
anyone upset but like I feel like people
that consume social media are very like
they it's very shallow and in terms of
how they convey this stuff you know
versus like the movie Joker for example
yeah won Oscars celebrated by the film
community and the Joker by far not a
good guy yeah yeah yet wins an Oscar
right it's a platform for bringing to
light mental illness and all these
things right so what if this is like a
way to bring to mind that there is
domestic abuse happening in the world
and it's not so much we're glamourizing
about we're just bring so it's how you
look at it yeah
the perspective thing I think if that
was the initial intention then I think
it would've been successful so if
they're if they're captions yeah it's
not like that Joker had that yeah cuz I
for me I think the part that I feel it's
unfair is people are just filling in the
blanks with their own insecurities are
and in and so like for me like if you're
filling in the blank with their own
insecurities or whatever you want that's
just on you and I think it should be the
intention of the person that put it out
is that's what they should get judged on
so if they're making fun of like
domestic abuse abuse then that that's
[ __ ] up cancel them do whatever right
but if they're just doing all look at
this really court that I made then just
judge it for that and don't film in your
own blame because what's happening is
they're going hey what if someone takes
this the wrong way but that's the same
argument they use in video games or bad
horror movies or whatever they go
what if someone takes this the wrong way
and gets influenced and they go out and
think that it's cool right so it's the
same [ __ ] thing but now being done to
this and the influences yeah I think for
me like both intent and how people
receive it matters right all of it
matters but instead of reactants who I
think you should start a conversation so
that person should go oh I do as this
way why do I view as this way let's talk
about that rather than be like I view it
this way you guys should definitely
apologize for what you did because if
you one read the captions but - it's a
mug shot so that person's in trouble
yeah no way can be the domestic the one
that got abused yeah yeah well it's like
them why would you even say they're
basically whoa they say that but like
all your [ __ ] like you're proving
domestic abuse on a novel glorifying it
but they were like you're just putting
some of that got beat up all that
stomach just domestic abuse you're in
jail that's domestic we said what
doesn't make it's the beater yeah it
looks like that person was really bad at
committing that crime that they were
right if anything if anyone had anything
to say it's
glorifying the cops beating up criminals
yeah if anything yes because that's
where my mind went immediately do is
like oh they got [ __ ] up by the cops
buying those criminals I just happened
to look too damn good which there's a
model yeah that one oh that became
famous off a mug shot that guy with the
blue eyes yeah cuz he was just too damn
and then with the people in the comments
especially girls were like he's innocent
like whatever he did forgive him I
thought it was innocent to those eyes
told me you looked that good you can't
be criminal
[Music]
[Music]